okay so people in my chat i want you to
know that the reason okay so there was
this whole thing when i joined the
stream
reason is you oh sorry and then hoover
snake showed up no i was like i'm
absolutely not buying v bucks i'm
vehemently against it
and then i clicked to this part of the
shop where i discovered the kratos
bundle which is currently 1
100 v bucks off for 20 hours and i was
like you know what
i am going to do it so
i can't throw the leviathan axe what
garbage is this
zombie is gonna put down a little color
and we're gonna fly to it
okay okay get the space and then just
okay okay
and then just w key your way to success
doing it i'm doing it i'm doing it
well i don't look like i'm gonna land
anywhere near that oh no i'm doing it
you're going to
just just yeah go to it if you don't
land directly
at it tip just go to it okay so have you
never played this
only once and it was like years ago okay
okay yeah this is very different
okay did you ever play tetris
never heard of it okay it's nothing like
that a video game
yeah yeah wait there's already people
here oh
no they're everywhere oh no
all right so you just run around and
collect the guns where's your people
okay the battle
a fishing rod should i take that i
didn't
expect that to be oh bullets
[ __ ] right here bad guys i mean i
get lots of them
oh my gosh right here oh oh oh oh okay
hang on
no no i mean i got you i got you i got
you i got you i got you i got you no
no no i don't know i don't no i don't no
i don't no i don't okay
okay okay you hit her in the face
shake her down alana once you lift me up
we'll shake her down steal all her lunch
money okay
look at stephen bullying yeah
excellent okay i feel i feel like i'm
doing that am i doing good
you're doing it am i playing the video
game you're doing great sweetie okay
thank you
okay okay oh my god kratos with an
assault rifle
is the content i never knew i needed
come right here
we're going to splash you with our stuff
wait is it actually healing is this what
they call chug chug juice or whatever
it is
shake them shake them shake it all right
we're going to jump into this little hot
tub here
we're going to have us a good old time
okay yeah let's go we're going to just
chill in this hot tub until
all right we're on the hot tub in there
this
juice or whatever yes it is yeah so it
actually absorbs through our feet into
our systems
there you go yeah this is for your
little light show oh
oh yeah i like that this hot tub
actually comes on the show
are you naked
i think you might be naked has anyone
ever told you that before that's just
body paint
you a hoe you know
i told you let me let me let me do this
for you
yeah how nice you go naked go all right
why does music change based on where i'm
standing what the [ __ ] is this game
they're up above us i hate when they
have high ground
okay cool why are you walking around
with that
death scythe what are you uh because
it's my pickaxe take yours out right
trigger
um
[Music]
right trigger
it's your harvesting tool you need to be
harvesting so you can do things like
this that's pretty sick but also
what if i just shock people alana yes
you guys got a car yeah well steve i
know you can't drive
all right well i can now so the the
orange you gotta take the orange truck
there
what if i want to sit on the back of
this one what's going on oh you'll die
you guys put me in my own truck am i
really that embarrassing
what the heck happened to the back of
the truck that happened when you started
driving
yeah it's gone now it doesn't live here
anymore it doesn't live
happening we're just gonna pee on our
rides real quick that's how you fuel
them up
oh my gosh can you stop i just keep
shooting
oh sorry embarrassing what
is this video game i don't understand we
have to fuel up
lana have you ever you know this is
where i go
i think you guys are joking but i'm not
positive this could be a gameplay
mechanic
i'm going to pee on that okay there you
go there you go i'm feeding on your
truck
okay 100 fuel that's exciting
wait so that was real yeah that was yeah
we were filling up the doors
we're not joking people we're
i feel like i'm being trolled the entire
time that i play this video game i feel
like i'm
i'm am i being punk where is this
who is shooting at us oh you you're
shooting okay
[Applause]
oh baby is there like a better whip for
us
but that's all i can find okay
where am i where did my
why do i have a fishing rod i don't
but that doesn't seem like it belongs in
a battle royale i just don't
it gives you health or thermal sight or
all kinds of things
thermal sights from fishing yeah it's
like the fact that this music is playing
we're in a car like they're just there's
just a lot happening
this is tatooine because you wanted to
come over here
there's something behind us there's
somebody behind us he just jumped out
behind us
he's right here they trying to hang out
are they trying to die
they're right here they're right here
they are indeed right there
dead [ __ ] we getting back in the car
no the car is outside the ring but the
rings right here
okay i thought it was still closing no
no no no no better than that listen
why do you not believe in my trust me i
believe in you i saw you do it
oh oh what happened to me yeah you're in
you're in the sand now so you can like
run around under the sand yeah
this is not what i thought fortnite was
i told you
it is and hide
so that they can't see you under the
sand okay great when they come in for
this chest
we're gonna mess them up we're gonna
jump their [ __ ] yeah here we go
i'm like a bit stressed about it that's
fine we're stressed about camping
no just about the the the game it's like
a contrast
damn you're right we have yep we have to
win this game
are we about to win are we playing how
are we winning no we're not playing
astronauts
these are actual live people oh listen
my last match that i played
uh no offense without y'all i won like
eight in a row oh my god i love the
lightsabers
they have the lightsabers i miss them
they really level the playing field
my kd went from like it was point five
to like
nine why are you glowing
were you always glowing yeah why
now the sun's going down so like it
makes it twilight the ray tracing in
this on the new xbox is beautiful
i realized that every time i tried oh
let me shut it up
thank you so much i'll knock your ass
down i don't give a [ __ ]
oh my gosh we have to murder these
people
now i don't know i'm going to you're
pushing i'm approaching where is he
where's the other one why am i dead
[Music]
yeah first victory royale for alana
let's go
is this did i get punked did this really
happen
we won we really won our first game
i'm just so confused about everything
that i could but i'm very
happy i guess
oh you know take them wherever i might
go dump them in the seats oh they
exploded i just killed i just killed his
homie that's why i just shot him in the
mouth
sorry nice so how do i ping for you guys
i'm gonna assume it's that
enemies
there's more you are not gonna last
through this mate i don't even know why
you tried there was no way you were
gonna make that i had shot at you from a
distance so many times
get done my dude so you're not supposed
to kill them
oh why you're supposed to shake them
down so we know their fans are
that doesn't make sense i thought when
you guys said make sure you shake them
down i assumed the whole time that you
were joking that you would make like a
just shake them down
some kind of like fortnite meme
i'm gonna go to the beach to get some
health back hell yeah you're trying to
chill the beach i'll come with you steve
yeah
let's go to the beach oh yeah yeah you
can get a fishing you can get a fishing
rod and do some fishing
oh my god i don't have a fishing rod now
though i'll never know if you were lying
to me on you go to the beach there's
plenty
of things as an australian that is not
true wow it goes crazy
look at this it's all pink i come over
here
are people shooting at you yep that's
depressing
cool we got him i was trying to show
the bonfire i am it heals us
are we being shot at again people
shooting from their friend down so it'll
put a red dot over their heads
i'm gonna get out of here i don't know
why these people keep thinking they're
going to live
you know stop you've been hit so many
times drink what
i'm coming i'm coming i'm gonna come in
yo healing we're having a little bonfire
and you're healing
so oh i am well
here's a here's a fishing rod alana
so you could go fish so what you're
going to want to do is you're going to
see these little
oh snap we got to get the fluff out of
here
it's not even a bad storm it's just some
light rain how is this hurting me i'm
the [ __ ]
god of war you joking they see me
rolling
here
and catch some fish here okay so alana
you're gonna want to fish
all right you're damn right i am you
have a better chance why is the car
reversing
on its of its own accord it's a ghost
car
it's a goat have you ever heard you ride
in the ghost lane
that throw it and then you get a bite
you'll feel it and you pull it back so
you're you're you're you're a cat
so throw it throw it again no no i gotta
fish though i want to eat the fish
so wait till it bobs it's like animal
crossing but if it were really really
easy she's she's got a no it's all
garbage
you could get boats what the [ __ ] is
that watch this [ __ ]
oh my god
this game has to be destroying
children's attention spans it has to be
there is no way it is
all right so here's the great part y'all
here's the great part a lot i'm going to
show you real quick change color get
these
hit these yeah because i have my own
skins for boats
so when you hit these crystals it's
going to drop this right here
okay okay you're going to want to
consume it
you're telling me we're going to be
eating crystal right now
crystal yes yes have we thought about
the implications of this
and then just double tap spacebar
oh i did that one double tap space what
the [ __ ]
what it's amazing
i didn't expect any of this you guys i
didn't okay alana
look there's two uh white things in the
water right here mom and dad
oh i see okay
all right y'all let's go across let's go
across the road here
i will kill you okay i'll kill my friend
too oh okay
that's i like the way you think if you
want like i don't have to should we not
because they'll kill them no kill them
okay well so
we're just doing it can you can you open
up your inventory and put down the
fishing pole
okay yep i'm gonna show you the coolest
thing okay watch this right okay
okay all right so i'm gonna go over here
okay it's the joke that you steal my
fishing pole and run away
nope so
oh my god it's it's that move from
college when i was like
reeling in chicks it works now what it
didn't work for you in college team this
i can't this video game has so much
video game in it
have you ever considered putting less
video game in their video game
yeah okay so this right here
um alana if you want to take the splashy
thingy hang on let me consume the
crystals i'm trying to get high
how do we keep winning
because you got two of the greatest with
you i'm suspicious